2020 ein dann sind wir uns einig
herausforderndes jahr aber selbst mit
pandemie war doch nicht alles schlecht
bis jetzt eine freie autobahn wochen
lang schulfrei und ohne rose im video
konferenzen herrlich ach ja und die
sache mit dem strom
egal bei welchem anbieter man gerade ist
hätte es da eigentlich schon im frühjahr
richtig gute nachrichten geben müssen
deutschlands wirtschaft fährt runter und
mit ihr der energie bedarf an der
strombörse sank der preis deshalb
bereits um 30 prozent innerhalb von nur
einer woche 30 prozent billiger als ich
das gehört habe habe ich meinen 3000
paar cent windstoß 24 stunden am tag
durch laufen lassen bis mir einer gesagt
hat die konzerne haben den preisverfall
gar nicht an uns verbraucher
weitergegeben
ja es ist wohl so eine art naturgesetz
strompreise kennen nur eine richtung
seit der liberalisierung des
strommarktes in deutschland sogar erst
recht jahrelang hieß es wir sollen zum
sparen so oft wie möglich den anbieter
wechseln alles andere wäre total doof
plötzlich ist die wechselei aber gar
nicht mehr gefragt im gegenteil viel
wechsler die prämien und boni mitnehmen
werden sauber ausgebremst im schnitt
wird inzwischen jeder zehnte ohne angabe
von gründen abgelehnt
also über gründung habe ich nie bekommen
ich habe dreimal angerufen und die
antworten waren alle ausweichend wir
können entscheiden ob wir jemanden dem
oder nicht und wir haben uns gegen sie
entschieden weil wir dich nicht morgen
du wechsler
dabei haben manche kunden den
permanenten preisvergleich inzwischen
zum sport oder sogar zu ihrer eigenen
religion gemacht die lieben das nicht
auszudenken wenn man denen das wieder
wegnimmt das hätte verheerende folgen
für eine ganz bestimmte
gesellschaftliche gruppe
funktionierte studienräte mit zu viel
tagesfreizeit nimmt ihnen den
tarifvergleich und ihre frauen werden es
büßen
und am schluss landen sie natürlich bei
querdenken wollen wir das rettet den
tarifvergleich ja alles andere wäre
wahnsinn es können wir nicht wollen viel
wechslern wird der wechsel erschwert nur
weil die stromanbieter sich mit ihren
bescheuerten lockt dumpingangeboten
gegenseitig ins knie schießen wenn das
so weitergeht muss man seinen
stromkonzern bald sonne hat treueschwur
leisten wie wieso ein gelöbnis bei der
bundeswehr hat was traurige brannte am
rande einkommensschwache familien hartz
4 empfänger die preiswerten strom also
besonders gut gebrauchen könnten ja
hängen oft im teuren grundversorger tree
fest weil die hippen billiganbieter
sehen nicht nebenwegen schufa-eintrag
oder so knapp 300.000 haushalten wurde
2018 der strom abgestellt
manche mussten ihren dann selber machen
schlimm schlimm tatsächlich haben 85
prozent der mehr als 800 grundversorger
laut verivox in diesem jahr den preis
erhöht nicht niedriger gemacht erhöht
live zugeschaltet ist jetzt sebastian
pufpaff er ist geschäftsführer meine
stromanbieters abruf parat warum die
erhöhung
danke für die frage ich hätte sie mir
sonst selber gestellt was soll ich sagen
es sind schwere zeiten gerade für den
kleinen mittelständischen fairtrade
stromkonzernen von nebenan wie von
hofbauer geiler strom für dein zuhause
uns hat es da einfach eiskalt erwischt
corona da wird ja in einer tour
berichtet wie schwer es die pflegekräfte
angeblich haben was alles schlimm ist
aber was wir stromerzeuger durchmachen
da klatscht keiner vom balkon ja die
grossverbraucher die industrielle haben
wegen corona die produktion
zurückgefahren
letzten endes ist der grund für die
preisentwicklung das ein ganz wichtiger
verbraucher nämlich gewerbe und
industrie massiv weniger strom
verbraucht und über die umlage
mechanismen der netzentgelte oder beim
erneuerbaren energien gesetz muss jetzt
dieses geld auf eine andere kundengruppe
stärker umgelegt werden
und da kann sie doch mal welche
kundengruppe das sein könnte bingo der
ganz normale dödel von nebenamt wieso
denn ich wenn der strompreis an der
börse steigt zahle ich mir wenn er singt
dann auch
also ich immer nur ich ich ich ich ja
wir haben corona der hält man zusammen
da hole ich nicht rum wegen sind passend
dieses jahr hatten wir halt sehr viel
sonne und wind ökostrom den feiern sie
doch immer in ihrer grünen verseuchten
schlafschaf show für den gibt aber einen
festpreis und die differenz zum
börsenpreis übernimmt nun mal wer na ja
ich hab's ja kapiert ich
verbraucherschützer sagen aber selbst
die ig geschichte rechtfertigt nicht
eure preiserhöhungen auf erstens und das
können sie nicht wissen weil sie
gedanklich auf ddr niveau geblieben sind
in der brd erhöhen wir den preis wenn
wir bock drauf haben zweitens
preiserhöhungen sind überhaupt kein
problem den verbrauchern schonend
beibringen
wir haben heute eine sehr gute nachricht
für sie ihr strompreis wird aufgrund
ihrer treue und unserer einkaufspolitik
noch günstiger
doch beim genauen lesen zeigt sich zwar
sinkt der strompreis pro kilowattstunde
um gerade mal 0 2 0 1
doch dafür steigt der grundpreis also
die fixe pauschale um knapp 30 euro im
monat leasen die zweite seite von einem
brief ja bei einem porno gucke ich mir
ja auch nicht den abspann selber schuld
ja und das ist kein beschiss das ist
notwehr heutzutage wohl jeder gefühlt
alle drei minuten den stromanbieter
wechseln darf die sonne hafen note den
freier da muss ich halt mit tricks
arbeiten ja da kann ich nicht einfach
schreiben agp preiserhöhung für mich war
das offensichtlich ein werbeschreiben
ist sich auf dem deckblatt lediglich die
ostereier
doch auf seite 2 steht dass waldemar
kowallik demnächst 20 euro im monat märz
sein muss wo herr kowalleck schönsten
festgelegt
das ist mein humor sie glauben nicht nur
was alles geht leute buchen tarif weil
es eine blöde prämie dazu gibt es
fahrräder hornhaut oben
immer wenn die rechnen könnten würden
sie merken der tarif ist so teuer dass
kassel drei ipads verkaufen
ich sage immer wer auf so was reinfällt
der pink oder auch in der steckdose
ausprobieren ist eigentlich ganz geil
was ist das denn für ein menschenbild
abrufbar falls werden wir verbraucher so
doofe eingeborene die man mit glasperlen
verarscht ich will immer was sagen
freundchen ich werde in keinem fall da
steht auf der roten schleife mit der
annahme dieses kaninchens akzeptiere ich
eine preiserhöhung um 300 prozent
wirklich abrufbar hallo sebastian
pufpaff
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mimen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller
[Musik]